when artillery shelling and stray
bullets started hitting n rahman's home
she and her family knew they had no
option but to leave with two disabled
children they ended up in this room in a
school which has been turned into a
Reception Center in Northern
umur Muhammad my son got so terrified to
the extent that sometimes he cried alone
my daughter would bite her hands and
scream because she wanted safety and to
feel secure like they used to before the
war it affected them to the point that
sometimes they used to hit their heads
on the floor they used to cry and scream
so we left our home because of the
terror they lived
through dozens of other families have
also sought shelter at this center after
fighting between Sudan's Army and the
paramilitary rapid support forces
intensified in parts of umur Man the War
now in its fifth month has displaced
Millions While most have fled to areas
where there is no fighting thousands
remain trapped in the
capital many schools in Northern
omdurman have turned into reception
centers for those displaced by the
fighting in Harum some are here because
they're unable to afford bus tickets to
travel to neighboring states for refuge
for others umur man is home and they
have no relatives elsewhere in the
country to take them
in naat Omar was one of those unable to
leave the capital she came to the center
with with her two daughters after her
third was killed in an artillery
shelling but the war is never
far I don't have any money we've not
earned our salar since the war if we had
that we could have gone to any other
state because we're not safe here there
are bullets flying every day we're
afraid there's no organization helping
no one assisting us to
leave those who run the center say most
of the relief supplies come from the
community and the Army but their needs
go beyond just Food
Supplies people arrive in tough
conditions there's fear there's Terror
and a feeling of insecurity because of
what they've seen there we try as much
as we can to help them get rid of these
feelings so they can settle
here noon says as long as she stays in
the capital she doubts if her children
will be able to fully get over the
horrors of the war
but she hopes this Center will at least
provide some relief after being forced
from their home hia Morgan Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer